what happened overnight is being called
reckless by some european officials the
u.s embassy in ukraine is calling it a
war crime while the ukrainian president
is calling it nuclear terrorism
according to the ukrainian military
russian forces attacked and eventually
seized the facility surveillance camera
footage appears to show russian
artillery shells being fired at the
plant there are also images of a flare
lighting up the area there was a fire in
a building it was extinguished that
building is apparently used for training
and not a part of the plant that
generates power now the ukrainian
company that runs the country's four
nuclear power plants says although
russian forces are now in control the
staff is still working the company
however is not in communication with
them nuclear experts say active warfare
around nuclear power plants is something
the world should be concerned about
this is our worst nightmare come true
you know this is a
europe's biggest power power plant six
reactors
if it goes offline if we have nuclear
meltdown among six reactors this is
gonna be worse than chernobyl
the company says three ukrainian
soldiers were killed in the fight over
the plant two were injured
the russian defense ministry claims
ukrainian saboteurs would have provoked
the fighting meantime nato's secretary
general says the russian attack on the
plant shows the recklessness of this war
and the importance of ending it
mike armstrong global news cheshire
poland